hey everybody happy Thursday and happy
monster hunter day heck yeah
Janka gonna make some pants John Luke
I'm ready jump right into the pan we're
both playing here forget it we're not in
trowing we're showing your feed
your pants yeah I've got some pretty
good pants that took me almost 80 hours
to make so I've I've been deep in this
game guys I'm really loving it really
excited I can just okay I'm in I'm down
it's not magic I'm going to create a
session online should we should we make
it private or open later open it man
open leave it open let it flow
floodgates oh yeah oh yeah so I've been
playing a lot of this game having a
really good time with it how many hours
77 77 I'm 40 we're Monster Hunter boys
we're in it now so we're going to be
doing some high ranked hunts today yes
because we've gotten to the point where
we're past low rank at this point and
it's kind of a joke like if we were to
go and fight the first like great
Jaguars fight you have to do we would
literally like take you like 30 seconds
three shot it wouldn't be very fun so
we're gonna gonna be mess around with
that I think we're going to be actually
progressing John Luke's story and that
ghouls our plan yeah this is pretty good
so what's higher than high rank or than
high rank if you ever put drinks and I
think that's one thing I don't think
it's a thing right now it should be do a
squad search we're in the same squad so
I should be able to just join you that
way which is kind of nice
yeah yeah I'm all good my inventory is
all set I'm keeping all clean all the
time pants you know what I'm talking
about trousers if you're in the UK I
believe squad if you're excited bengal
mage well i mean so we showed up the
first hour yesterday we did it's kind of
giving you a taste of it if that's all
you wanted to see there you go that's
that's there for you definitely your
check
the deep stuff so I understand the
desire of not lying to ya get spoiled on
monsters and again we're very upfront
that's what this dream is about don't
watch if you don't want to sign that
stuff I'm also like I'm not gonna go out
of my way to like spoil stuff for you
guys I'm not gonna like Oh guys look at
my hunting log in literally everything
I've killed I try to try to like not do
too much but I mean obviously like we
said it's high rank so if you want to
stay away from that kind of thing I
guess you do know now and you know I'm
not gonna hate you if you decide to
leave I respect your decision
I want to get my login bonus really
quick oh shoot uh horizon zero dawn put
the story stuff aside you don't we're
gonna do let's go let's get our sets
let's let's do these event quests this
is great uh is does that mean like it's
in the room the Megaman stuff isn't oh
please let it be in here I'm gonna run
down sir is it in the room or do you
have to I think you have to do a quest
unlock it first so if you go into the
room you talk to the cat you can redeem
your downloadable content so here you
check there are much I'm gonna check
here you check there well we'll find out
what's going on in the middle and we'll
get the sweet sweet so if anyone has any
questions let us know
yeah by the way so even though some
people early have it you guys probably
don't because it still isn't out
technically told you know we are gonna
be trying to pull a monster hunter once
a week yes Monday's most wanted Mondays
and we definitely open that up to people
will probably make like a server that
put like the code up or something like
that we'll figure out how we want to do
that but we'll have we'll hunt with you
guys people join in on the hunt I think
the best way is that we tell people
here's the session and make it private
gamespot people can then join in yeah
then at that point it's alright you want
to get in on this thing so I'm looking
at I've got two event quest right now
and I think this is actually how we do
yes because I'm just getting I can get
some face paint yeah you you've got your
your immediate stuff so we we can start
this I'm gonna pick the easier one
that's just killing the the smaller
stuff
and we'll see where it goes from there I
keep like my current equipment also my
higher rank equipments much more
mismatched like that's fine well I mean
you can you can color-code
all your stuff to make it kind of go
together which is nice unfortunately the
color codings not quite to the degree I
was oh this is an arena quest the quest
has been cancelled go home get outta
town
why'd you cancel this quest bring this
quest back so because we're doing these
event ones where we're kind of lying in
that yeah I'm just gonna say to players
I'm so did you looking real good over
there I'm looking real good
or maybe we can't do it we can't do it
uh you can try to start it up but it
keeps telling me the quest has been
cancelled okay wow you know I'll try to
do okay one right I mean it's I don't
know if it was a zero yeah oh don't
don't argue lessons the wild is the
quest okay so we we can't get that one
I'm gonna want to try this one and see
if it works you try it I'm gonna go try
it on my end northwest camp except this
quest quest has been cancelled maybe we
just can't do it yet like it's it's in
but it's not in in I'm gonna go to the
gathering though because that is the
best way to do it gonna be so much more
of a game when it's on PC well first off
I think that's very rude to monster
hundred this game is I'm just gonna I'm
gonna double down well a full-blown
video game boy it's a very very strong
video game I am 77 hours in and I still
have story quest objectives I I haven't
seen like the credits we get em up no
I'm just going to the gathering hub okay
I will try post on a quest post that
quest but I'm very certain I'm in a
double-dip and I'm going to gas and the
game on the PC as well
I definitely so lessons in the wild as
the quests we've got yeah bow is on deck
the question canceled okay so maybe just
can't do it so all right well that's a
little disappointing we'll try again
Oh wolf 92 good to see you well then
let's just do one of my quest instead
hang out you know arm wrestle oh yeah
you want to throw down alright I've lost
every time epidemics does he pure out
that I think I'm getting sick to my boss
yesterday planted the seed in case it
arrives before they leave in the morning
that's a good call I like that it's good
more giveaways can't do that free of my
dude but we do we do giveaways
occasionally I don't think you're in my
game I hit I joined what I'm sitting
here posted up at the armwrestling
barrel and you're not anywhere to be
sprayed I'm not unless you're too scared
my god I'm not in your game how did this
happen are you too scared John though
maybe look at how how determined he is
why don't you send me a hot invite I can
do just that I need to back off the
barrel though
do you want me to go off of your screen
for a sec for I mean safety purposes
yeah go for it respect for my poor
friends that definitely don't want to
get spam send invitation way martha
Turner there you go all right cool only
on the launch take you do the horizon
armor alright so they must have just
dropped the quest in and that's not 100%
there yet but we can we can see it and
that's pretty rad so we're getting John
Luke in the game now we're gonna get our
stuff together and actually do a hunt
here I've been kind of messing around a
bit but it's ok though we're getting it
together so you guys count down we're
like less than a day away from everyone
being able to play
who's excited what weapon are you gonna
are you gonna Maine what are you gonna
do fill me in talk to me so that's how
we're doing we're doing great I'm doing
good yeah more monster is the story mode
touch of the multiplayer is completely
separate they are it's all connected
yeah you can totally play the
single-player with friends the only
thing you can't do is you have to wait
until a cut student finishes yeah it
once the cutscene finishes then your
friends can join which is a little weird
kind of annoying a time spy up you can
totally do quest with friends and it
both like says it counts on its really
red eye I really like the way that
you've said it all up I also like how
you can have like the 16 person lobbies
just like hanging out is this on ps4 ps4
Pro so I'm playing on an OG ps4 and
gianluca's on a pro and you're actually
you're doing framerate sold me on the
switch axe and yesterday's stream I'm
I'm really happy I was able to help help
make that be a thing you're interested
in
razvan knows a longsword all day all
night my dude I love the longsword so
much forget the haters it's a good time
so I'm 40 hours in I feel pretty
comfortable with my dual blade abilities
I kind of want to upgrade to a more
advanced weapon Oh apparently we need
more mic power Bob Jones say any more
bike power more mic power mics all the
way up great swords a good time
people are saying axe charge blade the
charge blade someone I've been thinking
about because I'm watching videos yeah
really cool it just looks really awesome
sheep now we're together we did it we
got it we got it all going in there you
want you want to throw down this is
every monster hunter Monday we should
start it off with a good old good old
arm wrestle you know it's to kind of get
it going you got to square up
mmm gotcha again
undefeated undefeated in the world of
Monster Hunter armwrestling I don't have
the the dexterity it's okay I've spent a
lot of years saving Maryland Metal Gear
Solid it's it's a good time okay your
stuff together and we'll let you choose
your your question on cuz you're you're
in the high-ranked like story stuff
right now I am I'm in a part where I
have to track down three different Elder
Dragons
at once so much yeah do a whole set look
so good all of the armor sets look
really cool if you're not too afraid of
like a monster spoilers or armor
spoilers we actually have a video up
where you can check out a lot of the
armor sets we've already found I can't
do that here dang there are some very
good ones and it really it's really
interesting because we literally record
all the stuff for that video yesterday
and then I finished a fight that I'd
been struggling with for a while and
then it a lot like three more sets
should make a male or female it kind of
comes out of how you want the armor to
look I end up going with a dude like I
usually pick a dude for my main
character and you can have multiple save
files so yesterday I made a female
character though you don't really you
don't really do alts and Monster Hunter
no but it's there if you want to do it I
solve those egg quests that I like never
you want to do some egg quests I can
cover you I make the very first quest we
do is the one that no one wants to do
how important our combos are not good at
them they're definitely a thing you want
to get to know cuz they're I mean it's
always good to be able to string stuff
together but you can spend some time in
the training room I feel like this game
does a good job of kind of easing you
into more difficult combat so I think
you'll pick up on some also there will
be tons of guides all over the place
youtubers will have some some guides up
and you'll be able to use all those cool
resources it's it's not too difficult
yeah
the main one that I use for for my
switch acts is literally like holding
the stick forward circle smash circle a
little bit hold or press right trigger
and then press triangle twice then
circle twice the game else was training
room which actually will give you some
basic combos I don't tell you like
everything but it gives you some good
like starting combos to use and then I
don't know like if you pick like a beat
more beginner weapon imma take dual
blades your combos I don't have now
you'll have it take it that's a nice
little trick by the way if you like that
have a friend who found a camp that you
haven't already found and then you join
them you just will find at the camp you
just you discover just like that also
this is good for me because the Deuter
about to fight has some elemental
attacks get that delicious food arm not
not as cool as the the other animations
for cooking but you know I'll take it
whoa you're way crazier than my meals
because I got that extra canteen upgrade
and it it's it looks good no it's pretty
good on a really hard monster we're
doing all high rank stuff so this is the
this is the tricky stuff heck you might
actually see us not complete a quest
could you imagine never we're good
finish I'm tired listening to you I
actually I'm feeling so my god mr.
monster hunter is in the chat the mr.
monster hunter below waiting for party
members apartment big fan of yours is
out of here take take us out of here
take me to the monster jean-luc I will
like the big sword on my back
Oh Angelo you don't even know it's also
an axe do you mean it says play mission
already I'm tired of listening to you
we're doing it I'm sorry it's taking so
long this dream is to listen to us so if
you don't like that I'm gonna talk a lot
but we're also gonna hunt a lot I don't
know we're building towards it it's okay
Yesi right dentist we discovered it
I'm not realizing I can only hear your
audio and not mine oh really oh that's
gonna be real fun for you oh yeah cuz
you can just go right into your
controller and stuff right yeah nailed
it it's true epidemic the love love you
guys I didn't actually work okay this is
an interesting way to come in I'm in do
it oh I took the parts you couldn't even
use it no all right I'm gonna grab this
this is some good stuff this is actually
not where you want to drop in if you
want to find this monster as a heads up
so we're gonna have to we're enough to
jump down a bit
oh man you know what I forgot that I set
all my audio off oh oh yeah cuz you were
uh I'm doing some recording I was doing
a specific thing I was trying to get
some very specific yeah that'll help
there we go now I can actually hear
things drop down here it's literally one
of the monsters that just hangs out on
the very bottom and we chose the camp at
the very top oh I found him nevermind I
knew he was in this area though so I was
thinking like maybe we just like jump
downhill there I'm just gonna start
fighting John Luke I know you're not
here but I'm very upset I'm raring to go
hello my dude and I go I think I may be
like nope I didn't mind
whoo slide on down get that mount almost
he's a he's a slippery one I just like
do this weird spine okay kill that
monster we're doing it
35 big monsters there's a lot those
little monsters what skin is that I'm
guessing you're asking for my gear maybe
oh is he already show them cuz this I
request what oh maybe it's cuz he was
crawling oh okay I'm like get it back
here come on
look here we go you guys gotta get that
sweet monster on her soundtrack oh you
have knocked me up in the air I want you
dude that it's all part of the plan can
you do that oh yeah one of the one of
the benefits of like using a larger
weapon is definitely leaping not
lighting we forgot to set the mood
lighting button but yeah you can you can
launch your pals up into the air oh and
you've got the no signal for the HDMI so
I'm using the palico buff like the buff
instruments so I just know that it's
he's electric and he's like a flying
squirrel lizards which I shouldn't be
mean about because my name is Otto has a
- it's true you know we're like kindred
spirits ooh hello I'm just gonna poke
this this bad boy down here
[Music]
oh here we go this is this is this is
what I want this is the good stuff come
on pokum no don't don't miss him like
that
dummy I'm within first time of the day
yeah she's already already running away
that's good do that thing the Toby
kodachi thank you that I believe that is
it is the monster we are talking about
that that's one of the benefits of
having a live chat is that you guys can
like that help us with our things that
we don't get what you know it's a little
not fun as if a raffle Oh shows up all
in the home yes you know it will happen
oh I guess you showed up just like oh
it's random nope oh my god this is bad
this is not what I wanted it at all this
is the complete opposite of everything I
wanted
so monster underworld one of the big
features is there are more than one
monster and sometimes just giant cluster
mess happens in every monster on the map
likes to congregate in all the oh boy
and now he's mad at me I'm trying to get
back up because they just kind of
head-butted me John Luke no don't die oh
no don't hit me okay I'm okay I'm okay
I'm dude is I'm just gonna jump off oh
my god Oh have all the mutaters
invariants
there are mutaters invariants so
probably what you're thinking right now
is like is there like a like a Pinkel
Rathalos or something they've got him
there here you get your monster variants
and it's a good time okay cool there's a
I don't want to like we're gonna die so
I'm just like I'm look I need to get
something I don't want to like jump in
at all cuz I'm just this there's so much
monster in one spot this is what I paid
for this this is what I paid Oh God he's
running away what our boy yeah boy I'm
outta here I need to leave then this is
perfect ready go no I'm good actually
hey wrap loads is not leaving me alone
he's a mean boy monsters hurt each other
or the Evangeline fight yes so some
monsters are territorial and if you lure
other monsters into their area they will
200% fight them and you actually get
point bonuses for making them fight
that's not what I wanted but also I just
realized that I walked the complete
opposite direction I can wait to get my
hands on this game I'm excited for
everyone to get their hands on this game
I finally was able to talk about stuff
last night when the embargo went up and
I'm just I'm very excited for new people
to try this game out yeah so I feel like
a lot of people kind of don't want to
jump into Monster Hunter because it
looks like there's like a huge barrier
to entry so that was always my thing was
I never played previous monster runners
because it always just felt like it's
gonna be such an ordeal to play down now
yeah so over the place it's all over the
place but I think this game actually is
very accessible especially for beginners
it has a really good difficulty curve I
feel yeah in the early game for sure
like it introduces players who are new
to the series very well like there's
some you see all the complex weapons
like the switch axe which Ben has but
there's basic stuff like the dual blades
that I have they're kind of meant more
for beginners and like it makes the game
very easy all right found him
same Hey it's like it's like we planned
this a hundred percent calculated and we
got the Mount Oh today's a good day
a good day to ride hard let's do it I'll
try to get these these tail hits in so
we're gonna try to get a carve on it but
yeah Oh
perfect we're just getting right into it
oh forget that the damage Archdemon mode
get the small combo in
yeah get it again do it again come on
yeah I do that yeah Oh got him up in the
air what is happening hello there oh
nice knockin down again got that
explosion if someone was asking if the
explosion affinity was in the game and
it 200% is it's my favorite thing do it
again one more time
no no how many monsters uh I haven't
actually counted but throw boy there I
can give you a page count there's like
four or five pages in the monster or the
monster manual for how many monsters are
I should have actually just counted at
some point but it's a very healthy
amount Bob Jones asking about the bullet
arrow farming it's not too bad cuz it
gets to the point where you can just buy
the stuff from the vendor in town you
can buy the stuff from the vendor in
town you can also set your crafting
thing you can set Auto crafting on
specific items so if you are someone who
uses a lot of bullets or arrows you can
say hey whenever I have the materials
just draft these for me which is really
really convenient actually I haven't
gotten like full into like no hundred
percent arrow or gun to like really like
you have a definitive answer but it
feels like they have systems in place to
make that what do we think of the armor
sets and bonuses I I really like the
armor sets they're still just as
wonderfully designed as they've always
been some of the bonuses very good the
set that I have on right now has a was
it like a your unsheathing attacks have
a chance to stun someone so anytime I
put my weapon away and then come back
and start hitting again there is like a
burger like a 30% chance I'll stun
whatever I hit it's just kind of really
cool stuff like that yes I can and I'll
give everyone kind of a heads up who
doesn't want to have it spoiled so they
can kind of like look away for a second
I'll show my monster my monster manual
but yeah wait do that I'm gonna sharpen
so I hope she follows you up
I should've sharpen before why it's also
speed sharpening a plus guys highly
recommended she's got a high threshold
then I guess it's not having any of
having any of it so we check sounds like
a popular weapon it's it's really rad
it's pretty cool it also just it feels
really good to knock things over
anywhere from like 15 to 20 minutes or
like if you're doing a real difficult
fight like you get that boy I need a
deal it could last maybe like 40 minutes
but everything is time limited to 50 hey
hey my friends are back yeah well I'm
gonna try to climb up in my wrap Llosa's
in here I'm okay they stick together I
guarantee he's going to show up here in
a second so they're kind of fighting
each other right now so now what I
wanted but
I'm trying getting something I'm gonna
join you
whoop oh this is not where I want to be
I'm hitting below this is gonna lose
that's fine
go home rathalos well you want after
this hunt all I'll do the manual will
give watch more later goodbye thanks for
joining us Monster Hunter the Monster
Hunter V monster was good senior Zach
thanks Zach yeah
do you monsters have a health bar no
they don't but you throw our visual cues
but you can kind of tell like when
they're limping and sort of like scars
that here on their body and there's also
there is a heartbeat monitor then see
next to Ben's mini-map yeah good idea
it's kind of faint right now which means
they're there it's kind of low and
they're there
oh you want it there outlier yeah it's
it's mostly off of visual cues like
their their breathing they're walking so
you kind of you gotta pay attention to
that kind of stuff to be able to tell
what's going on
hello yeah
also quick tip any time you pick up
piercing ammo or piercing Saphir your
launcher definitely try to get the look
the the long shot on it because it
basically the length of the monster
means that it takes every single hit as
it travels through it I don't that makes
sense oh oh no uh explosive boys here
what explosive boys here oh shoot oh
that guy yeah run away from honks he's
awful I don't like him at all
oh look you're not getting away from him
he he is on top of you yeah I
encountered this guy earlier when I was
fighting a pukey puke II and he I killed
it and then he showed up and was just
like just circling the courts yeah was
not letting me carve it out so what
thankfully able to eventually do it he
kind of shows up when you get to the the
high-ranked area right and it's kind of
like I hate guys guess what this doesn't
like we're not messing around now here's
literally a monster that's going to like
drop bombs on you from the sky yeah and
it he basically one shots you the first
time you meet him
also it's who I made my switch axe with
which is why it has explosive properties
[Music]
kind of like the I forget what it's
called I tried to remember it on my way
in
it's the the red the red dog creature
with the family oh go go go go gamma or
something like that the armor for the
great heroes I think yeah not great gear
oh sorry I was like a lizard the the
salamander that also was down in that
gross gross areas black one yeah
Google Armour I want it it's pretty
pretty rad I think it might try to sleep
here coming up which is good we can try
to yeah he's Lebanese devil trying to
creep on it she can tell he's really
hurt which means he might be retreating
to a nest to relax yes and sleep and get
some yep there we go
so if we want to we can actually get
some bonuses the material you should
come alright so then if we want to we
can I'm just gonna hit him with my
charge thing okay get like a free hit
that's extra damage
yeah and it's it's kind of cool that way
if we were doing like a caps request
this would be the moment to let's set
our trap yeah I don't really do are used
up with like barrel bomb just say that
that's the perfect time to set up barrel
bombs to anything you can do to get more
damage on is Oh dog Garen Oh dog Aaron
Oh Darrin there you go Oh to Garen that
sounds the sounds really family dog in
the name so okay you know it's good oh
yeah I really like it's what like 60% of
my armor sets from all right we're about
to have him knock on the floor here in a
second or he'll just fall over I guess
sure
yeah son says he's bombs all their
sleeping I don't uh I actually don't use
too many like barrel bombs I should
probably stop yeah you can you can just
buy them from the vendor which is nice
but bombs are very good very very good
big fan oh oh
cover me get off of that tree you yeah
there we go jump on him
break it up
[Music]
it's really surprised we haven't gotten
the tail off yeah no oh he's dead now
dead
no tail still I'm still on it like
getting it I tourniquet yeah now we want
to turn the bass right but I think it
breaks the party part though oh it's the
party not the game yeah because this
would just keep us in the backlog gamer
guy I've never played a monster hunt
game before what is a learning curve for
a noob like myself usually I'd say it's
pretty high and you have to like put a
lot of hours and like I understand it's
still all there like that but if it
looks like something you'd be interested
in this is the perfect game to jump in
on it with yeah there are tons of guides
and resources out there for kind of like
the basics of it which is really nice
but this game also does a good job of
kind of ramping you up and kind of
understanding like I I think the only
like really an advice that I gave you
before we jumped in I was like so what
what type of action game do you like do
you want to like do something fast or
slow and you're like I like Devil May
Cry and I was like do blades do blades
you know you you've been just going for
it like skill weapons and blood-borne so
but yeah so it's it's totally worth
jumping and highly recommend it
it may seem daunting at first but if you
give it the time you'll get a ton of fun
out of it I found it pretty rewarding
pretty much from the get-go oh that's
what they called me in high school the
rodeo champ and the ailment master oh
boy us to get some some Cool Hunter
highlights at the end - all fun show me
will show the manual I just gotta get
every it's a thing that everyone's been
talking about for a long time because
that leaked list came out and everyone
just wants to kind of like they want to
know yeah yeah that's where what we're
here for we're here this quest you can
show the manual right now morning is
this out in any it's not out yet but
we're less than 24 hours away from
everyone being able to get in unless you
get like an inter danced copy or
something yeah alright
so we're going to take a peek at the
Monster Manual so fair warning heads up
if you guys don't want to have it spoke
before you just look away for a second I
won't talk about what's on there I'll
just do a quick scan and let everyone
who wants to see it see it and we can we
can go from there it's my go in now it's
not a complete list mind you but it is
it's pretty filled up alright so this is
this is what we're looking at it's gonna
kind of slowly go through it and you can
kind of kind of pick it out to see
what's going on just have a good time
kind of kind of looking at these things
and doing it's really weird that I can't
talk about it what I'm seeing cause I
don't want to ruin it for people who are
still listening but yeah if you see
anyone you really like in there you know
get get excited some some good old ones
are back some some really cool new ones
are around some good variety some cool
stuff it's really really nice also if
you notice here there's an exclamation
mark on one of these this is one I
didn't know about until like literally
yesterday so I'm still finding things
I'm still researching so there could be
more than that how's the longevity
in-game ask
alpha Bravo uh I'm at 80 hours played
now basically and I still want to play
and I literally haven't finished the
story yet so it's the full game
difficulty higher because they're a
discouraged by the beta I'd say so
I'd say the fight against the near
gigante was probably a really good gauge
of what the game is like once you're
actually in it in it so if that fight
kind of felt more monster hungry to you
then that's a pretty good indication
there are still fights that are harder
than that and they're still fights that
are much easier than that but it's a
pretty good this is where the Monster
Hunter difficulty is chance I guess good
yeah is this game a more multiplayer
than single-player so that's an
interesting thing the game is definitely
better to be played multiplayer and it's
meant to be played that way
but they've set it up in a way where you
can actually play through most of the
game single-player and I'd say actually
all of the game single-player mm-hmm
even though we we all had copies or
whatever we'd only played a couple of
times most of my time playing was solo
which is kind of kind of cool was into
it to have that option bump them house
really quick oh sorry it's it's okay
that's the monitor keeps turning off
because we're it's just the computer I
should turn that off the computer goes
into like sleep yeah yeah so trying to
keep up with what you guys are asking so
was asking why the PC port is uh taking
so long and kind of sign how those ports
tend to not go that well so it's because
they are actually gonna be doing it
themselves like the development or then
put it off to a third-party studio to
develop the PC port the actual in-house
studio is going to develop it themselves
after your like they just were kind of
waiting for the make sure the console
releases were kind of like ready and so
hopefully that should mean that well
it's gonna take longer and it's gonna
come out in the fall that it will be a
much better port it'll be a good quality
it'll it'll be a port that is definitely
worth waiting for and like I said I'm
double dipping I think you said you're
double dipping possibly it'll be it'll
be worth it I'm excited so I posted the
quest you can join whatever you want I
will do that it's my crime wish list is
it worth it yes yeah I was trying to go
into like a like a Missy Elliott
reference but I couldn't I couldn't
remember the next line of the song
double-dipping just like destiny yes I
think I've already played more of this
game than I have of destiny though
that's good the story is yeah they do a
good job of kind of rationalizing while
you're doing what you're doing which I
feel like was kind of missing from the
other you know groundbreaking narrative
or anything like that I think it's a fun
story that just is good at compelling
you to like
keep going instead of just we need to
kill this monster outside of the town
it's more of like hey we need to stop
this because of this going into this I
know long the way yet Fred a lot yes and
there's just a lot of monsters going on
outside we've already been streaming for
45 minutes I don't even feel like it
pretty good alright let's go here let me
work it there you go
thank you we did it we got it together
alright I had my food I'm good to go
standby for departure is this a flying
ship looks amazing can you share more
details so that's the yeah so this is
where you can actually see all of your
friends when you're in your game you've
got some some cool chairs to sit down at
and you can do some cool emotes and hang
out but so the way that the multiplayer
works now is you can have 16 people in a
like hub and then from there you can
break off into different groups of four
people to go and do different hunts so
like say because I'm gonna have a bunch
of friends who are just starting to play
and they're gonna be the lower rank than
me I can still continue on my high rank
stuff and if they need help I can like
drop into their game because we're all
together so there's kind of that thing
going on okay I'm ready to go good here
I'm gonna stop being upset and step away
from this table we got tables you got
all basically everything you you need to
to hunt all on a boat there you can hang
out with your friends and just get it so
I can be a cat person you cannot be a
cat person yeah it it it's kind of sad I
think they took out the the palico
gameplay stuff how much work and impact
does your cat do pretty they start off
being able to heal you which is a really
big help than later on you can unlock
other tools to make them give you buffs
and stuff they have a full armor set and
it is there's some very adorable armor
so it's also check out that that armor
video because we did get some some palco
armor set up
l-3 if you want to see those but again
spoilers for four things if you don't
want to if you don't want to kind of
ruin that for yourself but it's really
cool to check out now we went to a
different thing that's okay that's okay
yeah well we'll meet up in the middle no
Ratheon okay so already have a little
bit I actually think I'm already
tracking what are we what are we hunting
this time I'd even look in okay this is
gonna be a fun time so I think I'm
already on the on the trail my my flies
are just leading me there cuz I've done
enough research where they just know it
yeah I've got a couple that's that's
super convenient that you do you put in
the work and eventually it's just like
oh I know exactly what it is so it's
gotten to the point where some of the
lower ranked monsters I've researched so
much that I think it just trust me on
top of them sometimes uh where I was I
did a whole bunch of research on the odo
Garen just because I wanted to like get
the armor set so now when I start any
quest with it like the last one I did it
literally just drop me right in front of
it and I was like I wasn't prepared for
this oh wow
that's kind of cool oh yeah are you guys
playing Dragon's Dogma I sort of I've
always kind of mentally Dragon's Dogma
so the interesting interesting thing
about Dragon's Dogma is I think some of
the people who made Dragon's Dogma also
were people who made Monster Hunter they
kind of used that as a place to test
like ideas okay so the games are very
similar in the way that they play found
diabolo scratches boy yeah he's a high
rank just a little too spicy for me not
good
I'm not prepared but uh I mean I I did
recently beat near Gigante so uh maybe
I'm ready for high ranked Diablos
someone says please play Dragon Ball
Fighter Z on tomorrow's release yeah
that's the point that's that's what's
gonna happen
it's got to be playing some dragon but
if you want to sweet sweet Dragon Ball
fights be sure to stop by tomorrow I'm
gonna play some tonight what's a box you
want to fight each other yeah oh yeah do
it what some fights I like this house
this game do you want a normal Xbox one
so we actually have not had Xbox
versions we only got ps4 we'll be
getting some tomorrow yeah
and maybe we can kind of test it out and
find out how good it is oh is that her
is that her that's our boy so wrath
Ian's I believe are actually Lady
Dragons the the rathalos is the dude and
the Radian is the the lady you think
it'd actually be the other way around
usually oh man
I thought you'd you jumped on him I was
like oh right up from the get-go no so
unfortunately that move I do I can like
hit him but I can't actually like him
who does a lot of my combo moves with
the dual blades are less about mounting
and more about just like doing this like
crazy getting in and messing back now i
mounted him there you go I'm gonna mount
them to in here in a second hold on can
we double now I actually I don't think
we can so I had my sword glow going but
it's a good chance for me to kind of hit
him a bit if I would just not swing into
the air Microsoft me off oh dang it I
don't I I guess I guess I don't mount
enough that like I'm kind of seeing
those tips I'm I'm trying to talk more
into the microphone for you but I am I
have the volume up all the way I'm a
very soft-spoken person I'm sorry well
we'll talk about her oh my goodness good
thing I got all these antidotes cuz your
boy is oh no oh it's not let's not talk
about what happens
I had a literal pixel of health that was
a real I just got got what was the wreck
of this what so rank rank 6 6 ok sounds
good sounds about this is about par for
the course for a Ratheon I guess you'll
come in and turn up the audio should do
as mer just gonna sit here in a little
play some Monster Hunter
they come up on this dragon and I'm
going to I guess made just the overall
vo was a little bit low and swing my axe
sneak up on it make sure doesn't know
I'm here
seems the monster spotted me I don't
know what's do from here in the run away
I don't think anyone's gonna hear me
either but hey you know we're getting a
go I enjoyed it I could hear it let's do
a whole like kind of like whispering
mumbly kind of like nature documentary
this game you have fast travel only if
you die you get carted off that's the
only fast travel you have oh actually
you can kind of like hook onto a dragon
and you can you can automatically travel
to it yeah that's that's true if I'm in
charge your spawn point oh I don't want
to be here at all it's gots claws up no
thank you
dude that's that's the other thing I'm
excited for because when you guys all
get the game and we're doing these these
weekly streams of this Monster Hunter
video game you all can come in and carry
us hold my beer I got this and that's
that's what I'm looking forward to I'm
looking forward to to getting in hanging
out with the community and having people
tell me how good they are and help me
become the best monster on record
because I'm I'm still learning I think
for like videos to come out right and
like teach me like no actually you're
you're doing this wrong like yes oh cool
like little did you know that the bow
actually has a really cool thing that
one shots every monster discovered it
well that'd be nice to know yeah right
if anyone knows about that please tell
me okay so did some audio work hopefully
it sounds a lot better let us know do
Ratheon salute tail flips you bet you do
that they - and they still poison you
every time you should get that tail off
definitely that is priority numero uno
you can't explore the whole world so oh
yeah people are a lot of people are
wondering about like is this like a true
open world it's not it's not open world
open world but instead of having these
segmented areas in the zones like you do
now the entire zone can just be walked
around freely there's no loading times
in between zones here you're both fine
I'm I'm glad that oh I guess sound is
we're getting the sound sorted it's a
it's a thing oh good I'm finding the
tracks for that one main quest I'm like
I'm looking at the chat and I'm
realizing that I'm like walking around
yes
yeah yes Macari devil yeahö is very
frightening oh I've never even seen that
thing he's you know kind of exactly what
you'd expect it really says something
that there's two monsters with the word
devil in them in this game yeah
whoa something else showed up no never
mind I thought something just showed up
just a Ratheon still just scary Ratheon
yes this is a I know it's deviljho but I
like I like messing with it yeah it's
like saying uh bagel I always say Big Al
because I feel like it's fancier and
more fun you gotta mix it up it's gonna
looks amazing on ps4 it looks amazing on
everything yeah I don't know what type
of weird crazy magic they've pulled but
it's a very beautiful game which is
something that I don't think anyone's
traditionally said about a monster right
I got that knock crit 74 that's pretty
good okay just calm down
I mean if you want to erect about it
down go for the tail I'm gonna go for
his head a bit you you got you got some
some some real spicy cuts that you can
do over there
[Music]
PSP was a good series I'm into it
I like admittedly I didn't really get
into like Monster Hunter until the wrong
way like like a lot of people I feel
like I gave Monster Hunter 3 a try
monster hunter tried to kill me please
and I ended up liking it from there
I'm not like an old-school Monster
Hunter guy but I'm been playing for a
while
I like the series a lot oh yeah trick
will come the future I'm fairly certain
will get G ranked at some point it's
weird that they just completely leave it
out like they'll add that later on there
couple of free updates I know they're
adding like screen update for having me
just one monster the pickle dinosaur
pickle boy very very tough I was
watching a video where so instance
that's apparently like look the big one
of the big bags in monster honor he's a
he's a pickle boy
there's my 4k there's a 4k clip that
we're currently uploading or are
uploading a 4k clip
we don't really stream 4k yeah
4k streaming is it's a little little
crazy oh here we go
this is a good stunt what its gonna
leave the area soon that's not what we
must be retracting we'll leave the area
soon unless I'm tracking the warm-up no
also that doesn't make any sense why
would you give us all that time with it
maybe there's a second one I don't think
that's the thing that can happen okay I
got just the same actually oh that
worked out well so there's one of those
tail flips that you're you're looking
for earlier ahead oh man oh that's weird
oh you know what no I'm attracting the
wrong one okay it's weird their
definition of tracking is weird I'm
technically tracking on the map the
raffle owes but I am gone was targeted
to the Diablos for some know what that's
fine if it's yah blows sleeves I'm okay
I'm okay with that
no don't oh I'm gonna oh hey
our boys showed up has he
yeah he's behind you then I don't want
anything to do with this I need to get
out of here we should know it's doing
the bombing run thing please don't is
that theme every time he comes in is
like the scariest thing oh they're
they're going to eat some stuff I need
to I need to take a breather a lot of
people are just like thrown out monster
names in the chat and and so monster
newbie I'm just like I don't know what
any of these are those sound really
scary sound scary though huh they're
anything like this guy sucks yeah I I
hate this one so much but I love him
because he gives me all the explosive
weapons I bet his armor is really cool
it's it's alright okay
it's not something I could get out of
here go home get away from this scary
bombing wizard does he just always show
up every time we he's he's kind of got
like a nemesis effect yeah yeah shows up
every time he's like man
trying to do a thing over here I see let
me ruin this man that rock didn't do
anything to you all right I found the
ruffian whoop same aah
bananas yeah it's fine attack oh I got
the tail nice see now we're not gonna
get you poisoned as much this is this
fights already starting to be a really
good time hold on I'm gonna carve it
you're going for the carve right now for
the car oh that's a risk you know I did
it shoot while you let her eat I don't
think they ate very much just because
the other dude kind of came in also I
there's there's the thing where I kind
of like I don't necessarily want to want
to jump in on two monsters when one of
them is eating theirs you got a way out
the consequences sometimes sweet flip
bro
[Music]
come on give me that mouth that's all I
want
oh when they're stunned now oh this is
perfect yeah getting that head hittin
all broke broke off part oh you went to
sleep that's a real weird time I don't
know why he did that but it's a
narcoleptic rathian we didn't know that
that's what we were fighting I don't
know how to say that I think I know he's
talking about though oh yeah they're
there they're still early yeah they're
still around you can like recruit other
tracks oh look just look at these little
dudes yeah that there you go answer your
question hanging out doing doing all the
things to do he's not happy hit him with
up with a bomb pod out of the air oh my
gosh nice downtown get dunked on
she's gonna fly away and I said no
material can I do it again do it again
make sure you get this tail oh all right
he's coming back uh one more time
no there whoa
I don't know if they're gonna yep to
come back down
so the slinger is also a really good
yeah change that they've made one of my
favorites a nice little tip the game
doesn't really tell you is when they
drop like those piercing pods when you
hit them they're really good to just
pick up and like shoot back at them yeah
it does like a good stun on them and
like some decent damage one more time oh
I should have waited till it was all the
way up that's okay
all right fine get you should get that
tail when I grab the grab the carve on
these things I better off buying the
creation look Rick yeah so I feel like
the grinding is a really good thing in
this game because I feel like I'm
constantly working towards what I want I
mean there are no loot crate's in this
game exactly there's no loot crate's
there's no season pass it's just all
here good old video game it's a cool
video game that you buy and then they're
gonna add things to it for free later
actually I think I should think yeah if
we go down this way it'll let us kind of
wrap my stamp oh okay there we go one
more one more
all right
yeah Luke rates are a real real thing
that are happening sometimes yeah I've
never been a fan yeah that's right
though so we're here playing monster the
luke rates are the monsters we got to
open up these monster Luke I mean you
know it is sort of random what you get
so I mean yeah right these are some
monster loot crate's I should buy some
barrel bombs for the next time
yeah let's I mean that's it's kind of
like a barrel bomb except it doesn't do
as much damage this is its home though
we're rain we're in the final stretch
come on come over oh I got there we go
get them out our boys back again Oh No
why do right where I put my healing well
I guess not gonna be using that very
much
you know my favorite part is gonna be
we're gonna kill it and then he's gonna
still be here we're gonna have to try to
get our carbs around him
that's what happened to me last time Oh
No why are you here who invited you
where that are just grateful Red Dead -
um I mean get this then get Red Dead
later on yeah I mean right she's still
not coming out for we don't even know
the real you state imagine not for a
while they haven't even announced it yet
but I imagine your maybe son who can
only buy like one or two games if that's
the case it's understandable which is
understandable but yeah I mean this
games pretty good so you're like there's
any reason why you couldn't get this and
then get Red Dead to you later down the
road if you really want to play a game
convince a whole bunch your friends to
buy this and then play it with them if
you can't we got it wait where you can
wait
get ready I don't know video games are
good both the games are probably gonna
be really good then on this one is I'm
talking myself into a material so the
the poncho that I have on is one that
makes them drop rare rare skills
I got a Ratheon plates and it's all
sparkly the plate is one of the rare
drops along with the gem so that means
you'll be able to build some top-notch
equipment chairmen with no rappy and
sweet Jack seems like a very good weapon
I like it a lot I like it a lot a lot
you will find a deal with it man do
there's more wrapping material over here
oh my gosh there's it's just a mess I
think you already got it yeah I'm gonna
punch this this this wasp
you guys are freaking amazing love it yo
stream thank you oh I'm glad you're
enjoying it well we'll be back on Monday
yeah more Monster Hunter and since some
of you guys will have it feel free to
join up yeah well we'll get some people
and we'll do some quests it'll its want
to make kind of a community kind of
thing you know exactly want to hang out
with everyone in and play some some cool
monster hunts with you guys we'll all
learn things from each other
we'll all grow together and be a good
time got a thing appraised sanity blasts
jewel one anti blasts that's pretty good
I could put that on to counter that that
boy yeah I mean what do you really want
to counter that boy well I mean just
like what I haven't I just want to be
around that boy I have to fight him at
some point
fair enough is this available on Steam
not yet no unfortunately it will not be
available on PC till later in the year
let's see we've been going for about an
hour
let's do at least one more one more
honey I'm in and then we'll game looks
great you look great and SZ the chat is
very far away so it's kind of hard to
read some of the names actually yes I'm
using the switch axe I believe you're
watching me of it oh yeah
oh you know oh you're gonna scale this
scale oh man what is this thing that we
had this is future technology that we're
dealing with it's pretty good oh man but
I can read everybody's name I may be
made the names too big no this is this
is fine I like it we all kill together
exactly you know what I'm coming from
you know where I'm at we're gonna all
make pants together actually I have a
pretty big ass I've an assignment now oh
really
to go pink we could do one of the
variants do you want to do it my dude
I'm so in so
we're talking about it we're talking
about those those cool variants and
mutations guys I believe we're about to
go higher you can free roam and just
encounter animals and fight or do you
have yes that question put in the side
so no so yeah if you want you could just
go to the exploration mode and just
fight them so you I can probably I can
probably go and look at it really quick
when I get up here but you can go on
expeditions and they will give you like
a forecast for what monsters are in the
area and from there you can kind of be
like oh today looks like it's a rathalos
with a Chance of angry fire pod guy
that's no good stay inside
so here maybe I can actually check it
out go depart on expedition and you can
actually pick any of the areas so I kind
of go to and it'll tell you like see if
we want to go to the rotten Vale will
have a rat Oban the odo Garen and a
great Jarosz and we've got the the
fisherman who's hanging out I want to
point out I'm 40 hours in and that fifth
area over in the corner yes I still
haven't even unlocked yet I realized
that I was I was in there I didn't know
if I wanted to like show that but I
there's another area that you unlock
after 40 hours 4 hours plus 40 it's a
this is a beefy game if you ever wanted
a game that has a ton of content
he's got your cover this game has got
tons of content ok what is this wrapping
gear I can make look okay you know what
do you guys want to see some armor sets
while Jean Luc's actually doing some
some crafting stuff actually can't craft
anything yet I still need more you just
check yourself out hope that the golden
silver Ratheon are in a hash tag content
I should check my armor because because
I have not upgraded weapons in a while
to Ellis the one thing we need is that
hot content talk content as Monster
Hunter already it's not out yet it's out
in less than 24 hours for everyone we
were just fortunate enough to be given
preview copies to kind of get our
coverage in order so we can kind of
deliver that to you guys and let you
know what's up the best we can but yeah
doing some some cool stuff some some
cool some cool crafting things create
those rapiers do it actually before I
even look at any of the armor stuff I
just want to like oh shoot I can't
actually upgrade my hatchet like a
really a really great thing that they do
and I showed it yesterday and I'll show
it again today for anyone doesn't hasn't
seen her doesn't know they actually put
like trees in for upgrading your your
weapons now a little convoluted look
it's it's convoluted but before that
didn't even exist like you'd have to
pull up a wiki to know like what your
weapon would go and yeah that's
ridiculous and now it's here and you can
actually like let's see where I'm at I'm
in the middle of this is the one I have
right now and if I want to build towards
this if I actually knew what it was I
could actually wishlist it and it would
track what I was gathering and it will
tell me how close I am to crafting it
which is really nice yeah we've got
we've got some cool cool armor things in
here you know what actually I'm just
gonna I'm gonna say you can check out
the video for it okay yeah because I see
that you're you're headed over to
picking out your quest
let's check I don't want to spend too
much time away from from doing the
monster murders exactly all right but
wanting to know about ranged weapons to
me fighting a pink a Jeunesse who so the
oh I should use a voucher
range lessons are good didn't do it
that's wrong I'm gonna cancel out and
okay
yeah range weapons are good I could just
they just it's literally taken from the
wiki like it's they they know that
everyone did it and they do more
something they need to do so they just
they robbed it in took it from there
that's which is really rad anyone else
have a full body pillow jean-luc or is
it just me
Miguel's get out of here Matt girls got
you it's my friend Matt oh I see he
likes to get in the chat and and you
just say weird things about me yeah
that's that's a good that's a good
dynamic I like it
hello Yuri how are you doing I don't
know why I'm here I need to grab the
quest first nothing can stop us Jordan
quests available quests assigned we get
that sweet spot for all the different
sizes there we go we can see it have you
seen this this cookie animation yet mmm
I have not seen to you one do you want
to see it show it to me you guys give me
this cooking animation so we got some
real real pieces of meat some the spicy
cats are on the side doing their their
spicy thing yep yep he's doing some
hibachi type like fancy just killing it
we got that cooking hype pala cows doing
it up every day Big Boss going going at
it just eating and drinking I love it I
love the part like no matter what level
you have of cooking I love how the one
cat just throws the dish cover up into
the air every time King spaghetti says
notice me I noticed you you've been
noticed I mean you didn't ask for me to
notice you but I'm gonna notice you to
anyway yeah oh dang their thrill we're
all into it oh you can start whenever
you want oh it's all good yeah so we're
going to fight this is an actual story
quest for you you've been is this one of
the ones that you had to track for a bit
mm-hmm okay yeah that the palico cooking
animations are so good and there are
multiple ones like it it goes up in rank
every time you upgrade your your your
canteen so definitely do the optional
quests help chef Kat out and make him
have the best restaurant in the whole
the whole area
chances are favorite troublemakers here
whoa
I switched my vo over to Japanese
recently oh nice uh yeah how you liking
that I like it
let's go you try the Monster Hunter
language it also very good
it's I kind of want to do it but also
I've kind of just gotten used to the
English stuff but yeah see it's out in
Australia New Zealand in a couple places
timezone stuff you can play early if you
say your castle to Japan whoo
interesting I think before we found our
boy there's pink a genetic difference
from normal a giraffe I think this is
just a regular a regular engine app I'm
sorry it's okay
said it said tickled pink I assumed we
were talking about getting a different
resolution I was that's what I thought I
was getting looks like a pink RAF pose
but apparently I'm just getting a dad
I'm sorry guys
but if you're looking forward to a pink
for Ethel oh well I get one okay maybe
next time
maybe next time on Monster Hunter
Mondays
coming soon to a twitch channel near you
a YouTube channel near you these are the
good old dual blades I might switch over
to the charged lathe I actually yeah
yeah do it do just tear em up yeah you
gonna be up that's the stuff that's the
good stuff the good I'm gonna try to
wail on the tail of it I'm gonna go
ahead
that that that was being very good whoo
yep yep yep dumb spine
dude you're jealous you're going in
right now once you know you're doing
with the dual blades is very easy to
look very cool with them yowzer nut
yield for a second uh yeah anytime you
get that and that jump off the tree oh
I'm really into it
come on oh boy I made it through an
entire Monster Hunter stream and I
didn't use a long sword feel good about
this
so I'm saying there's no pink rat flows
only rat the end we've been saying the
raffle I was like I'm gonna be honest
I'm keep interchanging them by accident
that I apologize if I've been saying the
wrong one it's also probably ice I
haven't been saying the right thing
either it's okay though you know what
we're talking about and that's that's
the good part
monster murders are just yeah I got on
them again I'm also on fires good god
Shirou cold leave some monster for the
rest of us I am slowly burning however
but you look really badass on top of
that that dinosaur while you're yelling
fire so still on fire still losing help
this is fine do what you got it I'm
gonna jump on them in and do a real
quick I
I'm not gonna jump on him do a real
quick thing I'm gonna fall off I guess
that's fine how many maps uh five five
one two three
looks like someone was asking about some
like graphical like differences and
stuff some was recommending digital
foundry yeah they had a pretty good
video they put out recently yeah they're
they're always good with their breakdown
with analysis the ones I always go do
when I'm interested in that stuff
definitely yeah they did a pretty good
one on the beta and I think they said
they're gonna do a full video
what's the games out so they'll probably
compare Xbox so they will have all your
questions yeah I tried to pretend that I
know as much as them but I don't it's
not really our wheelhouse no those guys
are that's that's that's what they do I
just try to play video games and have a
good time and make dumb jokes
dang my favorite part is ride this cycle
were like you jump down and then they
jump up and then yep oh the better one
time you're trying to jump down but then
they jump up and knock you and then
you're both on the ground we both on the
ground
exactly oh oh no I got another boy fight
each other do it yeah scream a bit get
angry come on it's got a yelling right
now yeah do that fight whoa this kind of
fun just to sit back in Washington right
oh it really is
there's no season pass no loot boxes
just video game why did they jump up on
opposite sides I think because I was on
the other side so I think one was going
for me I see I wish I could jump like
that okay don't why is this happening
please just fight each other stop
fighting us Oh
one of yous gotta run away at some Wow
I'm gonna try to jump in I'm gonna
that's my favorite move the engine it
has the added in his more combat
teleport
man Bharath you're you're good you're
good boy I'm glad you're here but like
don't be here yeah monsters playing tag
just running around good good go home
[Music]
our dual blades good for solo was a
weapon I enjoyed the most in the beta
yeah I played the majority of my time
I'd played solo I've been using the dual
blades they're fantastic that's what you
liked go for it there you go there's
does that dual blade endorsement yes you
grab this this cool or really quick also
you don't have to carry tools in your
inventory to do that type of stuff
anymore which is not Yvette you had to
have like pickaxes that were various
like quality types and they would break
so you had to keep buying them and they
take up an ant or a spot but you don't
anymore is that lag it might have been I
don't know I've seen stuff like that
happen before it might just be like a
big monster was in a place where another
big monster was trying to be so the game
so the engineer like teleport oh that
did not happen to me so that must have
been some wax did not happen won't do
wielding guns get that that cool gun
kata situation going on there so only
you could do that right well we'll talk
to our Monster Hunter people and we'll
tell them that we need those those
really cool do this for the next monster
for Monster Hunter universe bring us
duel guns off 300 galaxy Monster Hunter
galaxy monster galaxy 2 electric
boogaloo Monster Hunter Odyssey I'm
really looking forward to it's gonna be
a good time any range weapons irve-3
range weapons in the game there's a bug
on heavy bow gun and a regular bow all
of them really fun and bye
yeah bogans are sorry a regular boat was
probably my favourite of the range yes
angel and I'd switched to it for certain
monsters that are a little more flying
oriented I almost actually switched to
the bow for this hunt but the night so
yeah it's it's really good I think this
is the first time ranged has actually
been like a Bible like a really good
thing you can use and feel like you're
contributing it definitely works better
in groups but be warned if you're in a
group in your range is you will
definitely be putting out more dps and
you will pull threat and those monsters
turn around and look at you and they're
not happy so fun I I kind of want to
like build some dual blades there we go
so that's the other thing that I'm kind
of excited about is now that all my
friends finally get the game I can I can
like kind of use all their weapons and
build them up well I'm going through all
those right and it's like oh I'm gonna
I'm gonna play a bunch of really
requests I don't feel obligated for to
use my like high-level stuff say I want
to I want to have them like have the
same experience going through fighting
stuff like that yeah yes totally if I
play a bunch of my friends this weekend
I'll probably use that as an opportunity
to yeah and having the the scaling
happened with your gear and not like an
actual physical level oh I got for that
oh that's a real bad place to put that
I'm sorry okay you went to sleep for a
sec we've got all these narcoleptic
monsters like we're doing a thing maybe
one of our like our boys are
it's very possible Oh got it
we're glowing get up on there yeah that
bang didn't knock him over though I did
it on this leg and everything it's done
don't you guys think there are too many
20 monsters it's never enough monsters I
think there's plenty of monsters yeah I
have not been disappointed in the
quality of policies there are some
monsters I haven't fought in 80 hours
yeah
it's that I think that's a pretty good
indication of it why is the barrel doing
that granite also I'm new to this series
so for me all these monsters are brand
new but in your experience do you feel
like there's enough new monsters I feel
like you did a pretty good balance of
new and old and I feel like overall the
monster count at least has been pretty
good but I mean it's it's not like you
know the like crossover games where they
have just tons of monsters that can just
kind of reuse cuz they had to recreate
all so yeah that's the thing right is
you know this is like high fidelity
you're seeing these monsters and render
than the way they haven't been before so
if they were ever to make like a follow
up to world where they could kind of use
the same assets risk them up a bit like
they could theoretically make a ton more
monsters because it's like well we
already have you know all this stuff
from world or you don't we need we do
need dumb bombs really badly uh someone
wants to know if you use range weapons
does it change how much armor you have
you don't get less armor but I do have a
bow that is so big it gives me a
defensive bonus yeah yeah armor and
weapons are completely separate from
each other there's no yeah and also
armor doesn't have like a physical
property in terms of like weight or
anything so you can wear like the
clunkiest looking armor but you still
moves the same as someone who's just
wearing like a really light look
yeah like feathers Seeger whatever but
uh yeah oh I went the wrong way that
does a really dumb choice
somebody said super monster hunter world
that's the name that's one that's the
ticket super hyper monster hunter e^x +
alpha rainbow edition rainbow Edition
get you one oh dude he just stomped you
out I turned for one second I'm like oh
he's jumping and then I see your name
pop up
oh those real good does that's fantastic
I was great I'm a big fan
not that you died big fan of just how it
all that went down now me too that was
there we go ya know we don't have the
tail off yet I'm gonna move on run down
to the back
thankfully keep plenty of mega nutrients
on me so even though I just lost my food
bonus I can get some help
oh yeah so people asking about monsters
health yeah they they don't actually
have like a health bar or anything you
kind of use physical tells on a monster
to tell where they are health-wise so if
they're tripping and falling you can see
he's kind of got like that he's
breathing kind of hard this guy's is in
bad shape oh yeah and you can see the on
your mini-map is actually a little skull
oh yeah emanating from him that's how
you know he's dying I see he's he's
limping real hard he's he's on he's on
the way out I almost feel bad and it
might actually be limping back to it's a
lot of mobsters have places that are
kind of like their homes on the map and
that's where they go to kind of
recuperate so if you leave them to kind
of go off and do their thing they will
heal a little bit inside of there but
yeah this guy is seven a rough time of
it on armor looks so cool - all the
armor sets in this game looks so good so
so good I was gonna try to try to jump
up
oh if he goes down the hill I'm gonna
jump on him I think he is I think this
is actually where is like yeah home is
let's do uh do a jump arrow I got the
tail with it
nice oh boy that was real flame actually
there's probably a dumb idea but I just
breathing fire it's imal oh don't worry
I got it I totally got that tail me I
karoon ease your palico however
you know he's real good at that and
that's that's why I love him oh we knock
him down I'm gonna tickle his feet right
there really quick with my sword I'm
just gonna you know what I'm gonna make
this as dangerous for us as it is for
him and I'm just gonna break all the
poison alive he's already poisoned which
is really nice sounds awful to say out
loud it's kind of mean when you think
about what we're doing
yeah but he's there's a reason for it I
mean you know we're not it's not
senseless my quest Locke told me to my
quest log told me to I've got to make
some sweet pants out of this t-rex there
are children who need pants people who
need pants we need to restock the
canteen so chef catkin can make us
delicious meals with his cat pals again
it all it all folds into itself without
any meals we can make with this guy tons
tons of me that's a lot of meals this is
a ton of food 20 times tons of food
I don't need like one more head
wondering how long we think the dlcs
will keep coming if they're like other
monster hunters it'll probably keep
happening for a while yeah I don't know
if they've said they think they have
maybe a little bit like moss turner
games historically have gotten a whole
bunch of DLC quest it's like on the
regular they all have like a special
gear I don't know if it's gonna be
similar to like Monster Hunter for
America ultimate or any of that that's
the one I can think of off the top of my
head say they added like a dr jacket at
one point for doing like a hunt in an
arena oh there you go I'm knocking more
stuff off stunned
yeah oh I'm gonna have a really cool
most fight screen I'm very excited for
that yeah so the way that the crafting
loot stuff works is you get you you get
actual carves off of the monsters after
you defeat them or from breaking
different parts of them we got a plate
got a gym oh that's that's like the the
rarest one just get all the I did use
the uh oh there you go so you get the
cars but you also get bonus parts if you
get the tail like breaking stuff yeah go
and you get the bonus stuff after it's
all over
and from there you take those parts and
turn them into pants you can't tame but
you can capture and capturing gives you
more loot but it's more difficult yeah
but yeah actually we found it to more
difficult at least on the earlier ones I
imagine the like so you can't even
capture Elder Dragons it's basically
kill them or get got yeah
stop hitting that monster it has a
family oh my god had a bunch of crest
reward so if we get even more items like
it's pretty like that you know I'm gonna
yeah I'm gonna save that for for the
precious memory grab all this Jim I got
three gems what yeah get out of here go
home I've got to use that voucher man I
can't believe this I don't know what I
know I got the canteen upgrade finally
see this is it's all is it was this the
the canteen Questor no it was it was
just a regular question now but it says
the canteen upgrade you were the rodeo
champ this time and the all-star DUI
rodeo that thing like three times yeah
you did
do you play the game already oh we have
preview copies so we're able to play but
it in less than 24 hours everyone else
is gonna be able to jump in and it's
gonna be a great time but that was that
was your fight like 200% oh thank you
you're you're killing it
Jacob asks how did I get here I don't
know but thanks for being here I'm glad
you're here though it um it's a good
time and real happy ooh
greetings from Portugal Wow hello hello
is it sort of it's it's out its out a
night it's a night at at midnight or
nine o'clock if you're on the west coast
I don't wanna keep talking to this very
close to finding that mystery monster Oh
your first mystery mystery boy mystery
boy I can't believe I can't believe I
saw and finished the story in this game
there's ridiculous it's I can't oh I got
a bunch of school people to talk to cool
things to do I got to talk to that
traitor dude you're weak look all that
Mouse again but sorry
well we're pals went away I can't I
can't read the chat oh I have someone to
talk to
Bounty's actually I get some are
mysterious delivery they need it for the
ancient trees fertilizer research but
I'm sick I mean my hands are tied right
now anyway good luck Wow okay sure I'll
do your work for you I guess
8.5 hours to go for me see work where
people are getting real close it's
happening guys
monster honors here yeah Bob I'll change
the PC options after the stream is over
I'm talking about that is the game good
worth picking up I'd say yes
I fully recommend this game i doubly
fully recommend it if you can get some
friends to play with you
it's blast it's a good time there aren't
many other games like this Andy's gonna
buy this game after work hopefully wife
doesn't kill me if you buy her a copy of
spire copy bring her on a hunt yeah
he'll be it'll be a good time the lobby
looks so gets incredibly yeah the game
is very very beautiful which is I I
guess I still can't get over that a
monster hunter game looks really good so
huh world looks fantastic been playing
monster area since milestone or freedom
unite it's your you're in for a treat so
it's a real good time yeah so I kinda
had this I feel like a lot of older
Monster Hunter fans had kind of like the
same reaction one that first got
revealed where we're like oh man I'm
this is gonna be like a dumbed down
version for console baby children that
you know whatever and it's not that it's
it's good for newcomers it's good for
people who love the series it's good for
everyone I really have a feeling this
might have like a like a Yakuza kind of
effect where like Monster Hunters been
around for a long time but this is the
game where a lot of people will probably
get into it for the first time and
hopefully fall in love with it and we'll
just get more Monster Hunters you know
and I think that's a really good thing
yeah is it impossible the solo no both
of us have played a majority of our time
solo and we haven't really run into any
issues at all entirely so lovable but
definitely more fun with other people
any starting weapon advice I'm tanking
so I'm thinking a Lancer Lancer is good
I like Lancer gun Lance is cool if you
want a little bit of a range option
oddly enough like a great sword could
probably do it
tanking situation pretty well because
you can guard with it and the guard does
a pretty good job of negating damage
yeah I think you're on the right track
one more you know what yeah let's do one
more yeah one more one more for the go
around the hunting horn does have a
straight-up taun hunting horn is also
kind of a I feel like it's more of an
advanced weapon but if you really want
to deep dive into it
yeah just like just like mistaken saying
it's got what you're looking for but
it's kind of kind of difficult
well it's don't Lance isn't ranged but
you can shoot bullets from it I guess is
what I'm saying it gives you a little
bit more reach than like just a regular
Lance would do some specific kill one I
want to I'm gonna check again really
quick and see if we can't do the event
quests so like what is fair is fair I'm
trying think about what to do the I
would like to just kill a few keep you
key because I want to get the armor or
might do that I mean it's maybe not uh
you can't do it in terms of escalation
for the stream it's probably not the
best one to end on fair enough
I mean we did just fight an Anjanette
though I'm down to fight whatever that's
that's the great thing about Monster
Hunter any anything you're killing as a
progress towards opposed to the quest
but I can't so we can't do it yet see
craft some pants
gube you know have some new oh wait you
have I don't know if we want to do that
even though it's the time quest yeah cuz
after two quests that goes away yeah
let's not show that one yes let's save
that one we don't want to spoil
everything what happens we'll save that
one I just want to let you guys know
jean-luc is biting the bullet and not
getting a chance at a rare monster
because he cares about you I should
still have if we do one you'll have one
more go at all just honestly I'll
probably just go do it later
yep that's fair that's fair to do like
maybe right after so I miss my chance ah
so my other two optional quests they
were just
than drafty and we already fought those
I want to fight something new no one's
seen ya take it take it down there if we
need to let's I did that one solo but I
don't know if we want to do that don't
let this one yeah do you guys want to
see us fight oh rathalos and irathient
at the same time cuz that's what we're
looking at you know what let's do it oh
boy oh boy
I guess that's that's decided then I'm
gonna use a voucher on this one oh I
already I already ate oh not for me I'm
gonna grab an entire stack of dumb pods
because we're gonna need them into it
buy an entire stack I mean three because
it's all I have
sources vouchers purpose so you get
vouchers through the daily login bonus
and I think there's other ways to get
them too I'm not sure what though yeah
then you can use them you can use them
for a couple things you can what do you
activate a quest you could say use a
voucher and what it'll do is you will
increases your chance to get like higher
better materials so it's a pretty good
way of guaranteeing you can get like
something better you can also use it on
a meal and what it'll do is it'll give
everyone in your party a free meal which
is actually pretty cool so if you want
to be like a pal you help your friends
own free stuff you can yeah maybe I'll
switch up my weapon I don't want to do
long start maybe I'll use the I saw
someone mentioned the bug Lance the bug
books so I gotta watch this new
animation oh it looks so good in in the
the framerate mode too so I think I'm
gonna go bug Lance bug stick bug stick
it up
just to kind of change change of pace I
want to switch weapons guys I'm gonna
stick with my same weapon for now for
this tough fight actually here I'll
throw this out you guys want me to bug
Lance or do you want me to do the bow so
we haven't done any ranged stuff but
with them actually there might be a good
thing question you can just walk around
and kill monsters without doing quest
you can just go at any point you could
just say hey I want to go head out and
explore yeah you ready are we waiting to
see if people want you know I'm just I'm
just gonna say we're doing Maus 100
Mondays well we all just do other other
stuff yeah it's fine well we'll do
insect leave I'll jump around a bunch
oh there's some some good cracking that
happened there a reposition a bit
it seems pretty pretty evenly divided so
far on the chat so I made the final
decision I like I like being able to
vault up around no one uses the gun
Lance I'm not I'm not a big fan of it
that's kind of just me all right
all right oh they gave us dumb pods we
don't even I need to bring them they did
nice I'll take the throwing knives let's
see you get your own throwing knives I
get my own throwing knives I get the
dang pod I did the quest ones really
quick oh oh we went to different areas
we did let's fight we'll meet up in the
middle again I am feeling that I know
where to go anyway
we can kind of temp them out if we need
to by driving the road I kind of have a
lock on the Ratheon oh nice I like where
this is going ready there's also an
engine ass in the area apparently so
that's gonna be a really I'm sure our
boy might show up maybe not though
because this is actually technically a
quest you could do before high rank yeah
sorry Leo we're looking at chat from
from multiple places so as I'm seeing
more than than just just one place but
yeah yeah miss good gun lands players
I'm not one of them I could try to mess
around with it and hope that I can like
learn it at some point but it it's kind
of cool but it doesn't it doesn't do a
thing for me okay I'm just gonna run up
top okay yeah I'm at the top where the
rapa lows usually grab that egg yeah
oh you gotta have the egg what's down
here it's up there no egg over to the
right inside that that nest up there at
the left this oh no back back right
there Oh nope there's no egg in there
nevermind we can't we can't make it run
out unfortunately that's okay because we
got a trail and I'm if you're activated
this damn thing
yes Devin to me the first first rathalos
fight and it was pretty cool it's a heck
of a time was it I think it was the
first video that was going around a bit
from the beta was when
lirik did it oh yeah yeah it's like the
first time anyone had ever seen it
happen it was a really crazy time okay
well I haven't I'm a trail oh I found
them yeah I found I found them but how
long did you which one did you find
blows off on the wrath the end
Oh eyeing away well which one should we
go after they're gonna meet up
eventually that's true yeah Rathalos I'm
saying isn't it
rathalos Rathalos I've been saying
rathalos these are the words
where's game spot news haven't seen an
episode since last year I still getting
stuff together I think yeah they're kind
of like doing some like reworking on
that trying out something new with it
yeah that's kind of still in in the
stages so no word on when that'll be
back but there see yeah coming back this
guy's flying around and I wish he'd stop
flying around okay wait so I think I
know so the bad thing about like trying
to track these guys down is like the fly
around a lot yeah which one are you
going after I think I'm following the
Rathalos now me too okay so we should
come back together here real soon it's
not too far away from me game looks grim
fantastic yeah right he's in a little
like tree area kind of circular Oh
flew away y-you saw me you knew I was
here as soon as you said oh he flew away
the bugs were like yep back down where
he came from
it's okay this will eventually catch up
to him
this will be fun he's building the
height for it yeah exactly
by building hype definitely buying time
it's true it's a game that's not for
everyone Monster Hunter is but it's
if it looks cool to you you'll probably
have a good time yeah it is skill
dependent for sure but I think they've
done a pretty good job allowing for ease
of like introducing like at a lower
skill level and kind of like ramping you
up to it like at make this is a game
that makes me want to get better at it
yeah
just talk about that that sweet red
extract life that's my favorite because
it lets me jump into the air and spin
around a whole bunch totally lost
I'm almost there I got it he's he's up
in the nest okay see where they are I'm
just gonna I gotta get away from these
little tiny boys I can fast travel there
the good thing about all this walking
back and forth is I picked up a whole
bunch of honey and I've upgraded my
first-aid stuff a lot I keep unlocking
more and there are at least I have like
at least 60 I think easily so I have the
rathalos here I don't do we want to jump
in should I jump in yeah yeah I'm at the
bottom see what man I almost just just
do it just start that fight got it
I'll make my way up to you yowzer
popsicle TL I came to our Chow that
aren't too easy yeah mushrooms perfect
game perfect that this game doesn't
really feel I haven't we hit a point
right it feels like it's like total BS
yeah challenge its it does a good job of
you know why you died whenever you died
cuz you're like oh I know this thing has
poison attacks I didn't grab the
weigh-in time I'm here oh the Watership
time for you to show up oh wow I almost
got carried away I need to get out of
here
jean-luc saved me jealous save me Wow Oh
pull me aside Oh hold on I got it
Joey hate a thing I almost fell down no
you couldn't do anything you gonna fall
down flying like that was a hacker way
to start that fight
yeah right also I employed same oh I
didn't bring up antidotes that was a
mistake
nope
it's really great because the raffia
hasn't showed up yet
give me that red extract that I need so
bad there we go yes I'm saying take his
tail we're on it we're gonna try there
we go
whoo
I think that you you stab faster if you
look a bug Lance I'd like to just lose
my watch an anime happening over there
yeah right it's a good time okay I'm
just gonna kind of show prefect there we
go stoner fect going for the tail I'm
gonna hit his neck because that's where
I am I guess
thanks Hank
whoo - good cat yeah
so the the lock on its it's helpful in
situations but I almost never use it and
that might be because I played like some
of the older games for they didn't
really have it at the the oil head silo
lock on was was kind of nice because it
just kind of centered your camera for
the most part I don't prefer the lock on
but specific area loved movies that I
was like trying to do when I was playing
never hit them and I feel like if you
turn on the lock on when you do it
you'll get it like the ones where you
like jump up on the mushroom and like
yeah if you turn on lock on you're
almost guaranteed to get done it's kind
of what bad
for yeah man she's not giving me a
chance
get back here just up in the air so much
ow we need to ground him bring him down
I've got the sweet bug stick that I hit
things with
I think it's a crafting thing oh yeah
Oh
Wesley's saying apparently you can
change the lock on to be like the other
tenants that's something to look into
because that would make me use it much
more yeah I I do not like the new style
very much at all let me hit your face
don't know goodbye
how's it going yeah no sharpened really
quick use the flash bonds ring of the
ground we should have brought Flash
bombs - Oh that'd been a good call flush
bombs are really really good make any
right but crap Flash bombs Oh
maybe I'll just jump down on top of this
one let's give it a good do it I'm
watching no Ike just like that
good effort good effort
that was that was that was hot yeah
right I was into it and I'm full
extracts now it's gonna go in
Oh God this is all coming together
awesome
cool yes down get that head oh you're
just doing flipping around going all
over Justin yes it is possible the hunt
solo yeah and yes all the DLC that's
coming up is is free three additional
monsters for you to monster hunts why am
i doing the things I'm doing it's real
dumb yeah won't he eat leaves we got to
remember that you get the tail yeah
definitely there's nothing worse than
forgetting about the tail you know it
happens to the best of us hey friends
here soup's on oh nice I'm just going to
try and preempt this really quick and
just like tell them no
rathalos please
focus on I'm trying to get the Ratheon
to run away I just got to slammed into
each other
yeah right fire
all right I think yeah they're gone I
chased my way by throwing poop at him
[Music]
oh boy
give me that red extract that I need so
bad
but they oh they ran away down there
Oh get the other one you jump down oh
yeah oh you forgot about the tail it's
fine I'll come back I'm gonna get it now
then I think they're coming up to you Oh
yep hello he's back oh yeah boogies are
back I'll just let you know we've held
on to one yesterday as we ended the
stream oh yeah we could uh we should we
should show the movie again so
definitely have you figure out how to
get more costumes yeah it tells me I can
do it but I haven't found anything same
yep oh these are the these are the
things that I like this is this is the
good stuff
yargh
me down where do you think you're going
get back down on the ground nice nice
nice
come on get him come on all I can do is
watch
it's hit its head yeah
no oh and the see the finds got it two
boys back here I'll get it in a second
or I'll try to get it
I think they're running away though he's
running away yeah he's right one do you
want to fight the wrath yeah sure okay
so we're gonna have to get both of them
at some point
all right you need to eat a ration
really quick I got my tail car I feel
like the the raffle is can feel a bit
that's fine you can deal with that
oh he's actually really close to dead
shoot yeah
maybe would be worth killing him how
long did they heal for I think they look
kind of just hang out until we even come
back but sure but like how long does it
take them I don't know if they're really
what wouldn't go for a while
yeah same this could be like a like a
science experiment
oh he's barely really close actually
oh yeah he's upstairs one could just go
on they're both going upstairs
all right let's I guess we're going
upstairs then I'll grab this cuz it's
probably gonna be helpful don't mind the
grinding the grinding is good though
like it's it's a good grind I'll go on
record saying that okay carbon and we're
good
I think Horner's much easier in this
game you should have to memorize the
songs it's shrewd cuz it
I've only messed with it a little bit
just to kind of see like what's changed
but they kind of like tell you what to
play kind of like predicting off of what
you've already played which is kind of
nice wake up
we go
oh boy she probably left it asleep
actually it was not a great idea knock
them down nice I'm gonna try to throw
more poop at the Ratheon go ahead you're
out of here you Jacob
game is good yes big yes
oh boy I keep getting that orange not
orange yeah God your wings out of here
you know what
it's a red extract extracting isn't
going very well
oh shoot I've got one right out of there
one more answer if you got to run back
to the if if you've got to go back to
the the thing to get some more that's
that's cool we're really close to
pushing so maybe we can I think I can
make it work okay we finish rathaway run
away
all right I'm good
[Music]
there we go that's that's what I'm
looking for
come on
I just want to knock him down so we can
like hit him
[Music]
come back there we go Oh
whoa
yeah oh my god I haven't I haven't
actually done anything there we go okay
halfway done with the quest we're doing
it this is good oh I'm gonna sharpen my
thing really quick and we're gonna get
the car then we're gonna go murder the
Ratheon oh I got and this'll be ale a
successful hunt another shell a scale
okay monster hunter freedom unite was
great hope this one matches it I feel
like it might if I feel like it might be
oh no guys I'm gonna say it uh I think
this might be my favorite monster honor
it's my favorite monster I fantastic we
did it yeah I but thinking I'm I'm I'm
not like as long time a fan is a lot of
people I jumped in on the third one but
of all the ones I've played so played
every single one since then do it I'm
like hold on I need to show people this
because I don't know if anyone knows
about it yet so we're talking about egg
egg quest before but guys you guys who
know know about egg quests check this
out you see that you see that game
changer are you seeing what I'm seeing
are you experiencing what I'm
experiencing so it makes it much much
more tolerable it's a really big deal
and everyone who hasn't played Monster
Hunter before is like you're probably
wrong with an egg shock trap I have a
flash pod there we go am I the father I
am now oh it's an egg roll we did it
okay I feel pretty good I got some more
potions some more antidotes and picked
up a couple flash pods nice I can use on
this guy I think
I think they're flying back up to where
I literally just ran well he is climbing
back up here we go when I grab this
flash bugger
babbling back yeah ed quests are a
special kind of hell and they're in this
one but they're much more tolerable just
because which is crazy because I did one
and I hated it yeah we're we're
literally like hanging out like playing
multiplayer I'm like oh man you have an
egg quest don't you he's like yeah
there's like I got this I gotta deliver
these eggs it's not I think they're down
below I'm just gonna jump off the top of
this waterfall I'm at the point where I
I've gone up toward town now they the my
little spirit dudes are telling me to
jump to my death
currently giant bug bosses where is he I
haven't seen any big oh he's right there
bug bosses yet but like I'm I'm so
holding out like I've got high hopes for
the the DLC for this game like I'm
hoping they bring back like a gourmet
gala big fan of that one I'm hoping they
they bring back I think I know what when
you're talking about but I think it was
in a monster hunter before my monster on
her oh I found you here we are
so you get for killing monsters more
pants man it's it's all about that pants
grind the pants the pants adventure the
quest for better pants Monster Hunter
[Music]
oh my god just
ya know there we go got what I was
looking for missed completely why no
fall damage very strong legs Scott just
keeps this is that stuff that I like
that's what I'm talking about
I don't don't fall over before I
actually get my special attack off
Houdini's Kate Dan quests - yeah they're
they're a heck of a time I've only had
to do like two or three of them and they
weren't they weren't awful yeah
and the tail is off man this is uh we're
doing it it's all coming together this
is a good call frog a quest to kind of
hold on yeah yeah don't don't don't
poison me please I don't want to have
anything to do with that come on just
give me yeah there we go
back in business
I'm gonna try to grab this boy he's not
looking for she's not looking my mistake
nice
coming in
yeah
knocking down to copses this poor thing
whaling on okay
oh yeah there are people in the chat who
are calling me Phil which is like my
internet handle because my name is Phil
on the in the game I'm really bad at
names I for some reason have gotten
myself into a corner where I have
multiple names that people call me
where's that tail oh yeah
all right I'm gonna sharpen this up
really quick and we can give some some
chase to this that's the thing and bring
this on home there are the the vest boy
clean queen misgendering it's Ratheon
and rathalos apologies I I even call it
like I mentioned it it's like when we
were first fighting one of them earlier
in the stream yeah and I still mess it
up like we both know but like when
you're in the heat of the moment it gets
it gets intense yeah and everything
that's a good boy I met a very good boy
on the BART earlier today on my way into
the office San Francisco is the place
for good boys tell me
[Music]
little sunlight little sea yeah right a
very scenic scenic place to fight a
dangerous dragon oh my god just please
get oh my god
there we go calculating got it do it do
it do it do it do it do it do it
nice doing the thing do the bug Lance is
one of the coolest things to just watch
like someone flip around with I'm that's
what sold me on it initially and I hate
the fact that like I definitely do the
the like err stuff too much but it's my
favorite thing right trying to be really
flashy about it and you're probably not
actually doing as efficiently as he
could be yeah but it looks red as hell
and that's what I'm into yeah we got the
the tail cut off we're doing it they're
hurting real bad I'm gonna try to put
some cheap shots in here we're gonna get
him out oh oh into the tree they're
gonna get caught in the vine trap there
we go now they're down I think it's do
my special thing that's why I have
that over there yeah in sick leave is so
good and I slept on it for so long when
they first put in the game know
initially man I almost almost there we
go
there we go you know if there's one way
to end a rathalos Ratheon combo quests
it's definitely with the slinger i'd get
this this cool carve that was a good way
to end this yeah right let's carve out
some stuff yes we we got a preview copy
so that we could get our coverage ready
for when the embargo is up for it but
right now less than 24 hours from review
is up on GameSpot you wanna go check it
out yeah big big fan of this video game
yeah I like it a lot and also if you
liked hanging out with us while we
hunted monsters and just talk nonsense
we're gonna do a thing we're gonna do a
thing every Monday everyone for the
foreseeable future at least for a little
while yeah until everyone gets tired of
us so please don't get tired of us we're
gonna invite we're gonna like create
like a session we'll assign up the code
so that people can just like join in and
play want to make it a community to
thing it's got its got a community
aspect to it we want you guys to come
and hunt with us exactly yeah that was a
monster hunter thanks for joining me Ben
thank you for joining that was really
good that was a lot of fun yeah right
yeah so today I got the review up and go
check that out we're gonna be back next
Monday also we should be having a pretty
cool conversation we did yeah yeah
with Peter Brown about this game going
up hopefully later today so be sure to
check that out and we will see you next
time a rodeo champion guys I can't see
it I'm a rodeo champ John Luke the rodeo
champ the rodeo champ
you